[Music]
this week on q a
author and duke alum william d cohen
discusses his new book the price of
silence the duke lacrosse scandal the
power of the elite and the corruption of
our great universities
[Music]
william d cohen author of the price of
silence what does that title mean
well there's been so much
said and written about this case when it
first happened some people think well
that's an ironic title you're talking
about the duke rape case i'm talking
about the duke lacrosse
scandal
once known as the duke rape case i
happened in 2006 and 2007 march 2006 to
april 2007 by the way it's still ongoing
that's another topic but uh at that time
it was the flight 370 it was the bridge
gate of that time everybody was focused
on it so when i went back to
research this and study this and write
about it because as a duke alum i really
wanted to know what happened
and there was never a trial in this case
and i wanted this book to be the trial
that never happened i was surprised
at how few people wanted to talk about
this how few people
were very happy with the outcome
that had been resolved in april 2007 by
the attorney general of the state of
north carolina which was that these boys
were declared innocent
which is a very unusual legal term
usually you know in a court of law
somebody's either declared not guilty or
guilty the concept of innocence is
somewhat foreign to
uh the legal profession
uh i wanted to know what happened here
and i was shocked at how
difficult it is it was to get people to
talk to me including people at duke in
my old alma mater when i spoke to dick
broadhead who was the president of duke
told him i was doing this his first
reaction was
why why are you doing this we're beyond
this this is over please don't dredge it
up and bring it bring it out again
the title the price of silence if i
figure out right in the book you say
that this could have cost duke 100
million dollars break that down
each of the boys each of the three
indicted players got 20 million dollars
each from duke is that known publicly or
is that something you found out that's
something i found out i was told that
repeatedly
i think
one of the players had uh
some publicity about this a few years
ago received a tax bill from the irs
that was written about in a detroit
paper and if you do the math the
arithmetic you can quickly get to the
idea that he was being taxed based on
something like a 20 million dollar
payment this has since been confirmed to
me
and
that was of course so that's 60 million
right there now there was also a
settlement with coach pressler who was
fired the lacrosse coach
there was one settlement with him then
they had to resettle with him because he
then brought a libel suit against the
university
when
they paid 20 million each of the players
guess what the rest of the players on
the team the non-indicted players on the
team also sued duke
to get some money from them uh 30 a
group of 33 of those players sue duke
that settle that litigation was resolved
in february of last year uh
they got a settlement cash settlement
there's one lawsuit still remaining
outstanding among three of the players
one including uh ryan mcfadden who wrote
that horrible email that caused a huge
count foundation at the time so between
legal fees settlement fees
pr spin uh legal investigations
uh basically it's 100 million plus at
this time give us i know you you don't
want to quote the specific words but uh
ryan mcfadden
uh email said what overall
so ryan uh was one of the uh sophomore
on the team he's one of the players uh
there he uh was never uh uh you know in
or near the bathroom he was never
accused of anything
uh he was just you know doing you know
the usual underage drinking that's so
prevalent but after the party he went
back to his dorm and wrote an email
thinking that he was just writing it to
his fellow players on the team
thinking that he was quoting a brett
easton ellis novel
or paraphrasing a bretty
ellis novel uh but basically he talked
about uh wanting to reprise the party
that they'd just come from and but this
time
he was you know essentially going to
this paraphrasing uh kill
kill the women uh instead of just you
know treating them like they did this
time and doing other things to them it
was a very uh unfortunate email a very
vulgar email
as a result of that email which he
thought he had just sent to his
colleagues on the lacrosse team and
again this was in march of 2006 when our
knowledge of social media and how these
things get around it's not quite as
sophisticated as as it is today
that email eventually got to the police
somebody from duke turned that over to
the duke to the durham police they saw
that email
this was about uh 10 days later after
the incident and basically all hell
broke loose at that point
people were being given the benefit of
the doubt
until that point
but once that email was made
public on april 5th after they searched
ryan mcfadden's room
the coach was fired the season was
canceled ryan mcfadden was suspended
from duke he eventually came back and
and it became
a huger conflagration than it already
was as a result of this email a couple
of quick things where do you live now i
live in new york city what do you do for
a living i'm a full-time writer
when did you go to duke i graduated from
duke in 1981
who was the president when you were
there a guy a famous guy by the name of
terry sanford who is a former
progressive governor and senator from
the state of north carolina and a great
leader and a great man and a great
educator and by the way i love duke and
i'm a loyal duke alum uh and i didn't do
this to
hurt duke i did this to
really try to figure out what had
happened in a dispassionate way again
there's a tremendous amount of passion
about this story even to this day
all one has to do is go on to amazon and
see already that i've amassed you know
25 one star reviews even the book hasn't
even been out a week and it's a 600 page
book so i'm pretty much guessing that
not many of those one star review
writers have read this book uh you know
my last book was about goldman sachs and
people have a lot of passion about
goldman sachs too but this is in another
realm all together
durham north carolina is where in the
state of north carolina it's basically
in the triangle it's in
the center of the state
near raleigh near chapel hill it's
called the triangle because you know
there's research triangle park there
which is a very very famous
biotech and technology research center
it's sort of anchored at the points of
the triangle by north carolina state
duke and unc and of course there are
huge sports rivalries especially in
basketball that we all know about
how many students are there at the
school
a duke has about 6 000 undergraduates
about 1500 per class
in the subtitle of your book the duke
lacrosse scandal below that the power of
the elite and the corruption of our
great universities
why did you expand it beyond the duke
scandal itself
to
our great universities well because i
was
amazed at a couple of things as i
uh did my research into this number one
you know duke an institution
like duke is not that much different
than you know a wall street bank that
i've written three other books about uh
you know it's a very secretive
institution they have their myths and
their way of doing business uh they have
this
a lot of power
in the state of north carolina and
nationally they have a huge
uh source of wealth in their endowment
which is approaching nine billion
dollars they're in the midst of a three
billion dollar uh uh endowment campaign
now where would that put them in
endowments at the universities nation uh
certainly in the top ten i think mit has
about 10 billion this will put them
right up there you know harvard has what
33 34 billion so they're not quite in
that league but they have an ambition to
be in that league and that's part of
this story is duke's ambition which is
extraordinary given that the school is
basically only 75 years old i mean it
traces its roots back further than that
but it's certainly not the 350 year old
school that harvard is
part of the reason that dick broadhead
the new president is theirs because he
uh was the former dean of yale college
and very well respected educator and
duke wanted to get into the top
uh elite of academic institutions in
this country
and also of athletic institutions so
uh it's a very interesting balancing act
that duke is trying to do really only
stanford and maybe northwestern try to
do it but duke has been very successful
at having top-notch athletic
teams and top-notch academics and i
think this incident
frankly the paying of the 100 million
has unfortunately corrupted the
university a little bit i want to go
back and this is a clip from cnn it's
nancy grace uh
back in 2006 right after this happened
just to show the intensity of this issue
as you said earlier it's like the 370
flight that went on and on and on let's
watch this
stephen miller uh what's your response
to the indictments handed down and the
arrests
well i think i speak for many students
when i say that we're very very
concerned
that two innocent people may have
possibly
just had their lives ruined lord you're
saying it's not possible or innocent
that's not even in the realm of
possibility not possible but a grand
jury has heard evidence and deemed this
fit to go to a trial right and we're
saying that never hearing what the
victim has to say you're saying the
green i'm not saying it i'm not saying
i'm convinced that you're lying and your
first problem is two innocent people i
said i didn't say that i said we're
concerned that it's possible that two
innocent people may have had their lives
ruined because this case does have many
irregularities and many inconsistencies
sister uh yes i do but i would
appreciate it assume you've got a mother
i mean what your first concern is that
somebody's falsely appeared don't don't
tell me what my first concern is please
my first concern when i first heard
these out of your mouth
what are you seeing there
passion man i mean this story
just generated a lot of russia's
judgment
a lot of passion it really had sort of a
dog bites man quality to it
you know the idea that these three
privileged elite
white lacrosse players had you know
raped a poor
mother a single mother black woman
trying to put herself through uh north
carolina central university by stripping
uh you know got people
cuckoo
how did you approach
doing this
completely dispassionately no but i mean
you know you live in new york city
when did you start working on this and
why i started working on it about three
years ago and
again as a duke alum i felt that the
whole story got completely distorted
first that as you saw with nancy grace
that these kids
are absolutely you know guilty you know
right off the bat and of course
mike nyfong the prosecutor didn't do
himself any favors by spending a week on
television regularly declaring these
kids you know guilty uh then the whole
narrative changed and next thing you
know these kids have been railroaded and
this woman is bipolar and mike nyfong is
the worst thing uh since you know as a
total antichrist and and
and the whole narrative got completely
turned on its head
and then you have a resolution where
these kids are paid 20 million dollars
each it's the university spends 100
million dollars you know to preserve the
brand and i want to know what happened i
wanted to be able to look back thanks to
these lawsuits that one of which is
still ongoing there's been a lot more
documentary evidence that's come to
light than ever existed before i was
able to talk to a number of people who
had never spoken up before and i'm an
investigative reporter and i just didn't
see that there was frankly that much
difference between goldman sachs and
duke university who did not speak to you
well surprisingly to me dick broadhead
would not speak to me i asked him any
number of times
i thought for sure
as
the president of duke university my alma
mater knowing my reputation as a serious
investigative journalist he would at
least have the courtesy to meet with me
to maybe even repeat what he had said a
hundred times during the course of this
uh uh event but he insistently would not
uh let's show the audience what
president brought her broadhead of duke
university looks like and this is from
his apology that he made back during
those times
duke university president richard
broadhead says there are many lessons
that need to be learned from the
lacrosse case speaking at a law school
ethics discussion he apologized to the
three accused players and their families
for how the university handled the
situation we did not get it right
causing the families to feel abandoned
when they were most in need of support
this was a mistake i take responsibility
for it
the three lacrosse team members were
charged after an exotic dancer claimed
she was raped at a team party back in
march 2006 a year later state attorney
general roy cooper declared the three
innocent of all charges these cases are
over prior to that though the university
canceled the lacrosse team's season at
the discussion broad had warned of the
dangers of jumping to conclusions if
there's one lesson the world should take
from the duke lacrosse case it's the
lesson of the danger of prejudgment and
our need to defend against it at every
turn
what else should he have said in your
opinion
well i think that you know this
prejudgment works both ways i mean
people were prejudging these kids
without the evident evidence being fully
aired there was never a trial here and
just as quickly just as quickly as
people pre-judged these kids they then
pre-judged crystal mangum
the the victim who then became known as
the accuser they quickly prejudged mike
nyfong the district attorney who had
been a well-respected attorney in the
prosecutor's office in durham for 28
years before he became the district
attorney
overnight he suddenly becomes this evil
conspiratorial individual who's out to
get these
three duke students i mean i think that
unfortunately the pendulum swung so
quickly and duke decided that you know
they just needed to get this behind it
pay this hundred million dollars get it
behind it and let's just move on i mean
i note with interest that you that clip
showed the picture of the lacrosse house
uh where this party occurred that house
has been wiped off the face of the earth
uh it was taken down and now it's just
an empty lot that clip also showed roy
cooper the attorney general of the state
of north carolina
when mike nyfong was basically forced to
recuse himself from this case in january
of 2007 he turned it over to my uh to
roy cooper who did a four-month
investigation before declaring these
boys innocent as you saw there in april
11 2007. you asked me who hadn't talked
to me roy cooper never talked to me now
it's his right not to talk to me he's
the attorney general state of north
carolina he's probably got better things
he needs to do but if he's going to
declare these kids innocent i would
think that he should
spend time with a serious investigative
reporter who's doing a serious fair and
balanced portrayal of what happened he
wouldn't do it and he wouldn't make his
investigative files available to me
either
go back to
the date of the event was march 13 2006
into the
morning of the 14th where is that house
on campus
so duke has two campuses there's west
campus that
great gothic
spread that everybody associates with
duke uh and then on east campus there's
sort of a neoclassical uh uh bill many
neoclassical buildings that was
originally trinity college which became
incorporated into duke it's about a mile
and a half away and there's a bus that
goes between the two campuses on a
beautiful you know tree-lined road
and then off that is this
uh neighborhood called trinity park
which again this gets to the problem of
the fact that the drinking age is 21 in
this country everybody knows that in
universities and colleges everybody
under 21 is drinking and they're doing
that on a regular basis the president
before dick broadhead nan cohan decided
that first all freshmen should be put on
this east campus
the neoclassical campus
with the idea that perhaps drinking
would be reduced and then she made
rulings about who could drink and who
could not drink on west campus this had
the effect unfortunately the unintended
consequence of pushing drinking into
these homes off east campus into this
trinity park neighborhood which is a you
know middle to upper middle class
neighborhood uh the boys uh you know
lots of people uh uh fraternity guys had
the houses that they rented off campus
and had big parties and this became a
huge problem in this neighborhood and
the neighbors were complaining
repeatedly for years about public
urination the loud noise the drunk
public drunkenness that was going on and
that became part of the perfect storm
that occurred here
in this neighborhood because the
neighbors were complaining so
vociferously that the durham police had
to begin to take notice and this party
happened during that beefed-up campaign
to try to cut down on the party the
three boys names i know we saw david
evans
whose parents live here in this town yes
who are the other two reid seligman who
grew up in
new jersey west of
manhattan new york city went to a school
private school called del barton and
colin finnerty whose father was a
believer not a senior executive at bear
stearns at the time right before that
firm collapsed which is of course the
subject of my second book house of cards
he's a big executive on wall street they
lived on long island
let's look at some video of reed
seligman back in 2007 by the way in 2007
when did when were they found innocent
april 11 2007. okay let's watch this
julian comes in and says
she picked you
and uh
i mean my dad just fell to the floor
and i just sat on the ground
and i said i said my life is over
what do you see
well it's you know very moving testimony
um that was given during mike nyfong's
state bar
hearing where he was eventually
disbarred from
and and then he fought he was fired as
well as the durham uh district attorney
um
very moving obviously very emotional
uh reid seligman uh was the only uh one
of the three
indicted boys who reached out to me i
mean i reached out to them most of them
said although they said no they wouldn't
speak to me reid seligman actually
wanted to speak to me
we had an email correspondence which i
include in the book
and then of course the lawyers thought
better of having me speak to him or hear
him speaking to me so that never
happened uh you know he had you'd have
to give him uh he had a pretty airtight
alibi
about where he was at various points in
the evening uh including you know
calling a cab
uh going to an atm machine having his
picture taken at the atm machine taking
money out then going to a restaurant and
getting some food at you know
12 30 12 45 in the evening
and then you know going back to his dorm
uh he you know he had an affidavit from
the cab driver uh who you know basically
testifying that reed sullivan was in his
car during the time that supposedly this
incident occurred now you know i asked
mike nyfong about that what do you think
about the reid seligman
alibi and
you know he made his points where he
thought it was
could very well have been
a manufactured alibi he had his doubts
about the alibi and he points to the
fact that when reid seligman
asked for the cab to come pick him up
instead of picking him up at that house
which is no longer in existence at 610
north buchanan boulevard he had the cab
go to a house around the corner which
mike nyfong thinks is very strange
behavior why would you do that obviously
he wanted to get away from that house
i has a suspicion
and and mike nyfong has this suspicion
and crystal mangan has a suspicion that
uh you know something uh untoward did in
fact happen in that bathroom it may not
have happened with reid seligman or
colin finnerty or david evans
although there's certainly questions
about david evans that are stronger than
questions about the other two uh but one
does get the sense that something
happened that none of us would be proud
of let's see a little bit of david evans
from an edward ed bradley interview on
cbs
do you ever think that if this
does go to trial
that
if you're convicted
you could face a lot of time in prison
do you ever think about that would you
sure
30 years i could go to jail for
something that never happens
based on a lie
what role did he play
he was one of the co-captains there are
four co-captains on the team three of
those
four co-captains lived in this house at
610 north buchanan
he was one of the people that arranged
for this party he was one of the people
that arranged for the strippers at this
party he handled the money that was paid
to them i guess they all thought it
would be a good idea to drink all day
and have these strippers come
were they in season
they were in the middle of their season
it was spring break
they had been practicing and they had
two games that week everyone else is on
off campus basically on spring break uh
there had been a 15-year tradition of
having this party during spring break
again why
they thought this was a good idea i
don't know
they had admitted uh without uh
and no one questioning it that usually
what they did was go to strip clubs
but they thought that this would be
better to have the strippers come to the
house rather than go to strip club why
they thought that was a great idea i
don't know uh one of the interesting
things um
crystal manga an unanswered question in
my mind is crystal mangum said there was
a struggle she struggled for her life in
that bathroom
she was wearing fake fingernails
she said during that struggle the
fingernails popped off
those fingernails were later found
and on one of those fingernails
on one of those fingernails was david
evans dna
with 98
certainty
which seems pretty high to me but i
guess sometimes dna experts say that 2
probability means that it's not related
at all but
his attorneys basically said it got
there
through transference and roy cooper the
attorney general in north carolina said
it got there through transference in
other words that he picked up those
fingernails and put them in the trash
which very well could have happened
except matt zash is the one who picked
up those fingernails and put them in
this in the trash not david evans and
matt sash another one of the co-captains
who lived in that house
said in his report that he did that and
even the police wondered why if matt
zash was the one who picked up the
fingernails and put them in the trash
why david evans dna with 98 certainty
was on that fingernail so it sounds like
at this point you think david evans was
guilty
i can't say that because we'll never
know what happened you know as donald
rumsfeld has said famously this could be
one of those unknown unknowns there was
never a trial i'm not going to be the
one to say that
uh you know he's he's guilty of doing
something there are just questions that
i would like answers to that we're never
going to get answers to because roy
copper is not opening up his files and
of course
david evans is not talking to me
where are those three
young men today
david evans works at a private equity
firm called apex partners in new york uh
colin finnerty works as a broker at
deutsche bank in new york
and reid seligman works uh went to law
school at emory and he works as a clerk
for a federal judge in camden new jersey
can you conclude anything about
the residual for those three boys based
on what happened to them i mean it
sounds like they've been successful
you know they've gone on with their
lives obviously they feel
terribly wronged i mean you saw reid
seligman's emotion in that clip uh you
know you saw david evans emotion talking
to ed bradley and that was that was uh
well before that was like six months
before uh roy cooper declared them
innocent uh they have been able to go on
with their lives interestingly when i
first contacted david evans he was then
at wharton the wharton business school
i heard back from wharton uh from his
attorney saying you know i really wish
you hadn't contacted him at wharton
because i don't think his classmates
realize that he's the david evans from
the duke lacrosse case so he's obviously
all you know rightly you know
gone on with their lives as as they
should uh you know unless of course they
got away with something which you know
we'll never know
uh i'd also tell the story in this book
of ryan mcfadden the guy who wrote that
email and his life basically has been
not ruined but almost ruined by the
email that he sent that night that he
thought was a joke
uh and he thought he was sending it to
his you know fellow players he's had to
change his name i i wrote as an excerpt
that from this book that appeared in
vanity fair about how his life has been
changed forever because of what he did
in the early morning hours of march 14th
on 2006.
it seems like that if i were the
president of duke or any of these three
boys or mcfadden or any of these people
i said i wouldn't talk to you why would
i
why would i want you to rehash all this
and remind everybody about what happened
down there
well nobody wants me to write about them
i assure you goldman sachs didn't want
me to write about them either but you
know i am going to do it i am thorough i
try to do a comprehensive and fair and
balanced job
you know if in fact you are innocent
and didn't do anything
i would think he'd want to talk to me i
mean obviously first choice was
i hope he doesn't write the book second
choice is i hope he gets hit by a bus
third choice is if he's going to do it
anyway
i want to talk to him because i want to
make sure he understands that i didn't
do anything remotely like what i was
accused of doing and if i were roy
cooper i'd want to make sure that bill
cohen understands that there was nothing
even remotely uh
anything related to what crystal magnum
said happened here happened if i was
dick broadhead i'd want to make sure
again this is a duke alum a loyal duke
alum somebody that once upon a time they
were proud to call a duke alum is
writing this book and i would think
they'd want that point of view to get
across interestingly bob steele who was
president of the board of trustees at
duke during this time former goldman
partner former undersecretary of the
treasury
working for hank paulson during the
financial crisis duke told him not to
talk to me but he did it anyway
and i have a lot of respect for him for
doing that and he told me what he
thought
was going on and what how this affected
him and and the board of trustees from
their perspective what did he say
well basically said it was
you know like a mcnamarian fog of war
and i start this book with uh a little
quote from errol morris who of course
did fog of war in the about robert
magnus about robert mcnamara has just
come out with this incredible film
about donald rumsfeld and basically he
was writing this about the jeffrey
mcdonald case something that he has
investigated very thoroughly and he
thinks there's a lot of unanswered
questions there but but the quote that i
used from him was you know we basically
the truth is out there and in principle
we can find it so that was my driving
force the truth is out there and in
principle we can find it i did the best
i could but i don't know that we're ever
gonna get to the bottom of this until
unless and until some of the people who
really know what happened who aren't
completely discredited uh
i don't think they're discredited but
everybody else thinks crystal mangum is
discredited they say oh she's now a
convicted murderer in jail for 18 years
for murdering her boyfriend which is
true
uh she is in jail now and they think
mike nifong is the antichrist so of
course nobody wants to hear what he has
to say where is he today he lives in
durham and he's you know
living on a pension he had to file for
personal bankruptcy
he's had health problems i write about
how he had cancer in the book and he got
over that uh he since had a heart attack
uh he lives
uh
you know a very quiet solitary life
and but he did spend the time to talk to
me
and uh you know get a chance to tell his
story that has never been told before
you've mentioned crystal magnum several
times let's take a look at
her this is after
she was found guilty of murdering her
husband boyfriend boyfriend okay here we
let's watch
still north carolina versus crystal gail
mangum file number 11 crs 260
we the 12 members of the jury
unanimously finally defended to be
guilty of second degree murder signed
november 22nd 2013
by four persons cyrus
bryant is this your verdict so say you
all yeah
ladies and gentlemen of the very
listening this year unanimous verdict
by raising your hand sorry i didn't
count
let the record let 12 jurors have raised
their hand the council has made them
[Music]
that has they're being asked
yes
miss brian could you please stand
she i believe is in a prison in north
carolina i don't know exactly which
prison
i've never been able to figure out
exactly which prison she's in but go
back to then march 13th of 2006
what role did she play in that evening
and how did it work she was one of the
two exotic dancers that the boys hired
for 400 each to dance for them for two
hours i can't imagine
what they were going to do in those two
hours but
the dance ended such as it was the dance
ended within about five minutes
and
you know at one at that point you know
there were racial epithets thrown there
was uh
uh
uh the suggestion that perhaps a broom
be used on the women
and that
they were hoping that the women would
get together and perform on each other
for the guys
basically it quickly got out of control
the kids had been drinking all day many
of them were pretty drunk
and they left the two women left and
went out to the other dancer's car
the guys came back out to that car and
asked them to come in they kind of
apologized and they said you know come
back in and finish the dance
they either uh some people say they
reluctantly went back in other people
said they decided there was more money
to be made and so they went back in uh
and next thing you know crystal found
herself in a bathroom she claims with
three of these guys who she says
brutally raped sexually assaulted and
kidnapped her the i.e kept her there
against against her will here is kim
roberts who is the other woman
that evening that they know each other
by the way before they've never met
before and were they hired out of the
same place yes but they didn't know each
other and they both got 400 a piece yes
so it was an 800 is 800 expense yeah and
how many boys were there uh about 45 you
know how many of those are across
players uh all but about two of them
and how many are there normally on our
lacrosse team well there were about 47
kids on the lacrosse team all but one of
whom was black and of course she said
her assailants were white so the the one
black player uh devin sherwood was never
uh never had to give his dna was never a
part of this whole potential being
indicted situation you also say in the
book that the boys originally wanted
white girls to come yes why didn't they
get what they wanted i guess they didn't
have white girls to supply so
they were given the option of black
women and they said okay that'll be fine
let's watch kim roberts for a minute
in the police statement she describes
the rape in this way
three guys grabbed nikki that's you
brett adam and matt grabbed me
they separated us at the master bedroom
door while we tried to hold on to each
other
brett adam and matt took me in to the
bathroom
were you holding on to each other were
you pulled apart
is that true no
did she give you any reason to believe
that she had been assaulted abused in
any
did she at any point that night say
anything about being in pain or having
been hurt in
in any way
she wasn't
she obviously wasn't hurt or because she
you know she was fine
the whole body language from miss
roberts is that that the other woman was
lying
yeah and she in fact first told the
police that this was a crock that was
her word
and then she changed her story as well
and basically said
you know i don't know what happened i
wasn't with her it's quite possible that
this could have happened to her of
course the defense
say she changed her story because she
entered into a conspiracy with nyfong
because there was an outstanding warrant
for her arrest because of a parole
violation for something she had done
and to reduce the cost of
that
you know the costs related to satisfying
that warrant uh she changed her
testimony where is she today i have no
idea
did you try to find her i did but i
wouldn't you know didn't even know where
to look
you suggested in your book that without
the
record from the knife on trial
you would you would have had not i mean
you would have
not had a lot of the material you have
here well again
there was there was uh mike knife i mean
it was uh go ahead and tell what
happened well there was there was mike
nyfong's state bar
hearing
uh through the spring of 2007 that went
even beyond
uh
the declaration of innocence from roy
cooper so there was all sorts of
documentation that was made public as
part of that then in addition to that
two sets
of the players the who were the
non-indicted players have filed major
lawsuits against duke and there was a
lot of discovery as part of that a lot
of depositions
and a lot of documentation came out of
that as well
that was made available what was not
made available was a roy cooper's
investigation which was the basis for
which he said uh they were in it he
declared them innocent there was like a
20-page report the score sort of skimmed
the surface of what happened but he you
know he certainly would not let me or
anybody else see his investigatory fight
what are your suspicions about roy
cooper the district he's the attorney
general for the students he's the
attorney general for the state you say
you say i think that he's running for
governor do you think by 2015 six
running for governor in 2016. he's
declared candidate for governor
i would just think that you know if he's
declared these kids innocent
that he should just make those files
open i i don't know what's in there
but the fact that he won't let somebody
like me see them
makes me suspicious maybe incorrectly
suspicious but i am suspicious so how
was it from a legal standpoint that he
could find them not guilty he found them
innocent brian which is basically not in
the legal lexicon in other words you you
get to a trial and somebody's either
guilty or not guilty the concept of
innocent doesn't even work doesn't even
kind of exist in our justice system so
he took it way out of that in fact mike
knightfong told me that on the morning
that he declared them innocent he was
told by
his two invested by cooper's two
investigators that
he was just going to say they're you
know not guilty
not this idea of innocence and so that
was a complete shock to mike nyfong as
well as well as to you know the other
the defense attorneys it was a shock to
everybody because using the word
innocent is not something that's usually
used in the legal context but go back
why would duke settle with these boys
for 20 million dollars a piece and pay a
hundred million dollars total i you know
that is one of the big mysteries of this
obviously that would have been something
i would have loved to have asked dick
broadhead but i did talk to a number of
uh board of trustee members uh uh when i
asked uh bob steele about this of course
he wouldn't comment but chairman of the
board chairman of the board bob steele
would not comment about the uh
why
they settled but other board members i
talked to would uh in and off the record
uh not for attribution basis and
basically the reason he gave they gave
was
that
some of the duke administrators early on
had who were not lawyers gave
the kids
bad legal advice which was essentially
don't tell your parents
don't get lawyers cooperate with the
police and basically this is going to go
away
so that gave
duke duke thought they had legal
exposure because of that
and
beyond that there was this desire to
kind of make this go away to protect the
duke brand
to to make sure that
you know this you know once it was
decided that these kids were innocent
that the last thing duke wanted
was to try to then have to litigate with
them about you know all of what had
happened so the easiest course of action
was just to
pay them this 20 million dollars have
them i presume sign non-disclosure
non-disparagement agreements which helps
explain why they're not talking to me
and they haven't talked to anybody
uh since they settled uh but it's not
exactly clear why duke felt the need to
pay these kids you know
people
get unfortunately wrongly convicted
all the time
and there are places like the innocence
project who defends
those kinds of people and tries to
reverse the judgments that were made
you know examples of people wrongly
convicted for murder spending 18 years
in prison 18 years
and getting 20 thousand 000
payment a year as a result
you know these kids spent other than
their arraignment
hour or two no time in jail no time in
prison and got 20 million dollars go
back to your own experience at duke what
did you major in as a history major
what did you do right after graduation
uh i was also editor of something called
tobacco road at duke which was uh
you know for duke considered a kind of
alternative quarterly magazine
i.e you know left of center but hardly
you know what somebody would call you
know flaming liberal
and after that i uh was a reporter in
upstate new york
and then i went to columbia journalism
school for a year
then went back to raleigh uh the raleigh
times which was part of the raleigh news
and observer the afternoon paper covered
public education
for two years there
received investigative reporting awards
from the state of north carolina
and then went to
columbia business school and then worked
on wall street for 17 years and where
did you work on wall street for those 17
years i worked first at g capital
uh then at lazard freyr which was the
subject of my first book
then at merrill lynch and then finally
at uh the firms that became jpmorgan
chase
do you have any idea how much money the
boys families spend on legal fees
what i say in the book is that they
spent upwards of three million dollars a
piece total
on on the defense it could have been
it's probably more at this point uh
it could have been more at the time it's
again something that's
just sort of a figure that's been thrown
out there and what kind of uh
financial shape were the parents in
well well
colin finnerty's father was a senior
banker at bear stearns a mortgage-backed
securities banker head of that
department so he he then subsequently
worked in various hedge funds
so you know they had the resources to do
this uh
uh reid seligman's philip seligman was
uh uh apparently less uh supposedly less
well well off uh and it was you know the
bail for each of these kids was four
hundred thousand dollars uh apparently
the segments had to borrow that money
from a friend and then appeal appealed
to the judge to have it reduced because
the friend wanted the money back uh
and then david evans uh his mother was
head of the lpga
is a big lobbyist here in washington his
father was a a partner at a
washington law firm and now works
for
his mother they clearly had the
resources and by the way
their defense team did an extraordinary
job of defending these kids
you know whether these kids got away
with something or not we'll never know
but they did an amazing job of
exploiting every mistake that mike
naifong made they made did an amazing
job of getting the state bar to attack
mike nyfong and go after him and file a
complaint against mike nyfong which
forced him to recuse himself from the
case and turn it over to roy cooper
where we know now that he declared them
innocent so david evans mother was i
know that she still is but she was a
lobbyist for cbs for a long time that's
correct as well here in town right
friends
um
so is there a is there a bigger lesson
to learn in all this that goes
beyond duke to other colleges is there
are
lessons of the law the legal aspect of
this to learn
well i mean to some extent it shows how
the legal system can be corrupted
you know from both sides it can be
corrupted by a prosecutor who is
probably too aggressive in making
statements
uh even though he believes in his mind
the idea was just to bring this to trial
uh you know clearly the justice system
was subverted here there was no trial i
mean how many times can you think of
where somebody's been indicted three
kids three people have been indicted and
then there was no trial to see whether
or not in fact they were guilty or not
guilty and then declared innocent how
long was there between the indictment
and the time that they were found
innocent about a year
the the indictment the first two
indictments were april 17th 2006 and
then the next one was i believe may 15
2006. i don't mean to be naive but how
can an attorney general just say all of
a sudden the three people are innocent
he quote unquote did his investigation
and he
it's not in the lexicon this is
unprecedented i mean that's why i mean i
i think you know uh i happen to know sy
vance who's the district attorney in in
manhattan uh you know remember the whole
dsk case i think that had it not been
for
this case which preceded the dsk case
you know he dropped that dsk case
dominic strauss khan dominic strauss
khan who was accused of
raping a woman in a hotel room in new
york
he was a he said she said kind of thing
you know they pulled him off the
airplane when he was getting ready to go
back to france he he dropped those
charts i mean he did not pursue charges
against dsk
and i think a large part of it is
because of what happened here in this
case so this case has had ramifications
uh among district attorneys all over the
country it's had ramifications among
athletic departments all over the
country in in elite programs to sort of
juxtaposition of trying to be an elite
academic institution with being an elite
athletic institution i mean not many
people try it duke tries it stanford
tries it and duke arguably has had more
success
even than stanford
and anybody who's been to college
anybody who kids want to go to college
anybody who wants their kids to go to
college
this is a cautionary tale about
how something as simple as you know oh i
think we'll just have a party
you know on a monday afternoon because
we're feeling sorry for ourselves we're
the only ones on campus and thinking
it's a good idea to invite strippers
can have this be an extraordinary
conflagration here is the ex duke
lacrosse coach mike pressler he was
appearing on espn's first take this is
back in june of 2007
talking about this case let's watch
mike pressler is now telling his story
in a new book entitled it's not about
the truth the untold story of the duke
lacrosse case and the lives it shattered
and mike joins us now to talk about it
and mike before we get into the book for
those that don't know the title where
did that come from
that was a very famous phrase
said to me by the athletic director at
duke
when he was trying to
tell me the season had to be canceled
and i implored him uh that he could not
cancel the season because he promised
the players there'd be no more further
cancellation of games until charges were
brought
if it wasn't about the truth what was it
about for the university
uh that's a very um many layers to to
that answer it was about a lot of things
it was a lot of it was about a people's
agendas
i would say in the faculty in particular
it was about a lot of prejudgment by so
many people at duke university not only
duke university but the entire country
where is mike pressler today
he's the head lacrosse coach at bryant
university in rhode island
and how did he leave duke under what
circumstances yes he said the athletic
director after ryan mcfadden's
email which was part of a search warrant
that the police had got to search ryan
mcfadden's room
and then it was sealed but on april 5th
2006 it was unsealed
and as soon as it was unsealed and
became public that's when mike pressler
was fired and and the season was
canceled in other words he's right they
were willing to suspend
you know
disbelief they were willing to just let
this play out until indictments came or
not but once that ryan mcfadden email
got unsealed
he was fired and the season was canceled
you opened the book with a kind of a
scenario about coach k mike shashefsky
the basketball coach for duke university
who i saw somewhere allegedly gets 10
million dollars a year to be the coach
of that team what was that story about
so i i was able to figure out he got
paid last year something like 9 million
dollars but that's close enough to 10. i
found this i think it was usa today had
this
so
dick broadhead who had been the dean of
yale college and very highly respected
dean and
a scholar english scholar i was
recruited by bob steele basically to
come to duke in part because they do
duke is a very ambitious school and
wanted to be among the elite
academic institutions in this country
you know top three top four top five and
they thought that dick broadhead would
be
the latest
uh
in a line of great leaders at duke who
had you know made this school you know
put the school basically among the top
elite universities in the country
and uh he was supposed to start july 1st
and basically even before he started he
was down in his office sort of unpacking
his bags both physically and mentally
and in came joe oliva the athletic
director
with the incredibly stunning news that
mike
coach k mike czyzewski had just been
offered a 40 million dollar five-year
contract to go coach the los angeles
lakers and so even before dick broad had
started at duke coach k was basically
threatening to leave to go to the lakers
for a with a contract that there's no
way duke could match
at least certainly at that time and his
first real test even before he started
his job was to figure out a way to get
coach k to stay and he did i mean you
know either coach k decided that he'd
much rather be a college basketball
coach than be a professional coach and
of course then he coach k won a
another title in 2010 giving him his
fourth title uh national championship
and he's become the winningest coach in
division one basketball history
but it was a very clear example of where
really the power at duke lies and that
is with
coach k i mean coach k is by far the
most powerful guy at duke university he
gets paid more than anybody else he gets
on national tv whenever he wants he can
get in the new york times whenever he
wants and people do recognize that and
if dick broadhead thought he was coming
to like the yale of the south where
athletics were kind of de-emphasized he
was in for a very different lesson and
that's
why he got schooled again during the
lacrosse case
at the end of year book you have i know
that's a chapter but a section called
the day numo
and you mention a lot of other places
and the problems that they've had in the
scandals they've had
cornell
vanderbilt
u.s naval academy
uh harvard yale princeton northwestern
wesleyan
it's everywhere brian it's an episode
what if you what in this section would
did you learn or what did you pass on to
us
what i what i learned is that underage
drinking is an epidemic
that binge drinking is an epidemic that
there's bad behavior that results from
too much drinking on campus and we all
know there's way too much drinking on
campus
you know president obama in january
pulled together a task force of his
cabinet to address the growing issue of
rape on campus
this is a an out of control situation
i'm not sure how to address it there are
people whose pay grade is far harder
than mine that are that are addressing
this but i suspect it starts with the 21
year old drinking law because that law
basically makes no sense every college
administrator and university
administrator on campus
across this country has to look the
other way as a result of the drinking
age being 21. this is a bit crude but
it's in your book and i want to read it
back it's from a dartmouth student
and it was written
for the dartmouth newspaper january
2012. he's talking about fraternities he
said i was a member of a fraternity that
asked pledges
in order to become a brother to
colon swim in a kiddie pool of vomit
urine fecal matter semen and rotten food
products
semicolon eat omelets made of vomit chug
cups of vinegar which in one case caused
the pledge to vomit blood drink beer
poured down fellow pledges ass cracks
among other abuses a little strong but
it
says something new why you put it in
there i mean fraternity is all that bad
well i mean
anecdotally we have these stories i mean
i think this is just one of any number
of stories i also tell the story of the
pledge at cornell
in a couple years ago who died as a
result of
too much drinking duke has had
any number of students died from too
much drinking
you know
what were you like when you were a dude
the drinking age was 18. i did drink but
i mean i didn't binge drink
you know occasionally i drank too much
like everybody i certainly didn't do any
of the things that are you know outlined
in this book did you ever hear at when
you were at duke of having a i never
heard a party where you had strippers
never heard of that that as far as i i
mean and i had lots of friends who were
in fraternities i never heard of
anything like that apparently it's a new
phenomenon coach pressler
the lacrosse coach knew about this
drinking that was going on while he was
coaching these boys well i mean
according to the reports that were done
about the lacrosse program it's very
clear
that he was aware that there was a lot
of drinking going on among his players
you know coach k
you know basically forbids drinking
among his basketball players
and the other coaches had different
rules but for whatever reason uh
pressler
uh was more permissive and it was more
accepted in the culture that the
lacrosse players were the were the party
players and you know they had these
women who hang around them who were
known as the prostitutes
so you know
clearly the evidence that came out in
these reports was that pressler knew and
didn't really do anything about it but
he wasn't the only one who knew other
administrators at the university
knew as well higher up who he reported
to and didn't do anything about it
either if you were meeting with
president broadhead and he said okay mr
cohen after you've been through this
look me in the eye and tell me what i
did wrong what would you say to him
i think what he i'm not sure frankly
that he
did do anything wrong he's been
criticized mercilessly
for
not coming out in support of these kids
sooner but he is in a very difficult
position he's in a middle man he he is a
fiduciary for this university there this
had al well before he even knew about it
this was already basically in the in the
in the legal system in the police system
in the judiciary system i mean the
district attorney was getting ready to
to open an investigation
i mean what could he do i mean he i
think he did
what he could do should they have paid
the boys 20 million dollars a piece i
don't understand that at all
except for just wanting it where'd they
get the money
duke is a very wealthy institution they
had insurance to cover this kind of
thing
aig was their insurance company
ironically aig
declined to pay i think they sued aig
and my understanding is that aig won
that lawsuit so duke had to pay this out
of their
their own money you say the house was
torn down in hawaii who owned it
again incredibly ironically
a group of these houses in this trinity
park neighborhood were owned by duke
alum
literally uh two weeks before this party
occurred in this one house that these
players were renting
duke bought these homes
from this duke alum because of all the
complaints
about the partying going on in these
homes and the fact that this duke alum
was renting them to these students who
were then having these parties duke was
the idea was duke was going to let these
leases expire you know the people who
are renting now can can stay there but
when they leave they're going it was
then going to they were then going to be
rented to
non-students so that this whole issue
would go away but unfortunately before
they could implement that program of
renting the homes to non-duke students
this party occurred and of course a
couple years ago
uh they decided to tear down the house
and now it's just an empty lot in durham
last question mike nyfong who was
the
district attorney in durham
was he right or wrong the way he
conducted himself
especially in that first week or so
declaring them guilty
i think he probably would be the first
to say he regrets all those public
statements he made he also was the first
to tell me why he did that again this is
the first time he's ever had the chance
to talk about it and a lot of people
condemn him for even having the temerity
to speak out and sharing his point of
view but his problem was that he was a
district attorney he was trying to
figure out who the suspects were who the
people were who may have done this and
he didn't have any suspects so he
thought that by going public by
describing what he believed happened
based on what the police investigation
showed what crystal magnum had said what
tara levassey had found in her medical
report that he could sort of smoke out
somebody who would feel guilty about
what they thought might have happened in
that bathroom and would be willing to
come forward unfortunately that didn't
work and so within a week's time he gave
that up and you know basically didn't
talk to the media again
and but he was crucified for doing it in
that for very publicly and during that
week the name of the book is the price
of silence the duke lacrosse scandal the
power of the elite and the corruption of
our great universities and the author
our guest william d cohen thank you very
much thank you
[Music]
for free transcripts or to give us your
comments about this program visit us at
qna.org q a programs are also available
as c-span podcasts
[Music]
you